it's earlier this morning at shootaround  which caught a lot of people's  collective attention especially those in  Boston  probably notably their front office he's  very selective who he gives that Jersey  to apparently he's calling somebody down  you got to be wearing green to start  with I think and it's gonna be that  little boy right there  [Music]  well the Jersey exchange quickly  becoming a customary part of the NBA  postgame let's go to Cassidy  Kyrie you're waiting to give your jersey  what's the selection process here I'm  just about to get a surgeon my dad you  know just glad that got my family in the  house and you know it means a lot it was  a great team win for us about